rocket leagues first DLC is out
it's called supersonic fury and here's a
rundown on what this $4 package is all
about two new cars the American Muscle
Dominus and then there's the Japanese
street racer Takumi both are real hot
and both come with their own unique
decals such as Dominus scorpions or
Takumi's copycat Riau
supersonic fury brings 5 hue paint types
brushed metal carbon fiber metallic
pearl pearlescent and wood in my opinion
would and carbon-fibre worked great as
accents and pearl and pearlescent tend
to work best with complementary colors
what good do your own vague to new tires
the soccer hubcaps Cristiano not too
shabby
what else do we have here spinners yeah
lastly two new rocket boosts and they
are equally rad you get nitro switch is
probably the most rocket team boost of
them all and then there's my personal
fave burnout which has a sweet sweet
sound effect that really brings out that
extra excitement for those intents line
up shots so let's mix and match first up
to cumin and burnout
yeah
go for it here here's Dominus with
nitros coming in hat
oh yeah good stuff well pleasant leaving
everyone and you have yourself a great
day
you